et on commence cette émission avec le
sénateur du jour bonjour Jérôme Bachar
bonjour alexandre Poussin vous êtes
sénateur les républicains du département
de l'Oise et on va dans cette entretien
commencer par la visite chahute du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron hier en Alsace il a été accueilli
sous les hués sous les bruits de
casseroles est-ce que je rembachère ça
montre que finalement le président de la
République va avoir du mal à aller au
contact de ses concitoyens il a expliqué
dans son
allocution qu'il avait 100 jours pour
changer pour donner des résultats et
puis le dès le lendemain Olivier Véran
nous expliquer qu'en fait on changeait
rien et je pense que pendant 100 jours
les ministres lorsqu'ils vont sortir
qu'Emmanuel Macron en tout
particulièrement visé d'ailleurs parfois
à titre personnel peut-être même souvent
à titre personnel pour son attitude ne
pourra pas sortir enfin tout sera à dire
très calfeutrée nos services d'ordre et
les préfectures savent très bien faire
cela mais c'est plus une sortie terrain
à ce moment-là et c'est faire trois
images et c'est ce qu'on a eu hier en
vérité il a eu des images dans une usine
fermée calfeutrée il ne va pas à la
rencontre des Français et d'ailleurs il
a fait un petit dérapage lorsqu'il
apparaît des casseroles
il a dit ce ne sont pas les casseroles
qui vont faire avancer le pays dans son
allocution lundi soir pas de dérapage
vous voyez un peu spécialiste à chaque
fois qu'il fait une intervention hop il
en a une un peu de mépris du peuple etc
il remet de pièces dans le juke-box et
ça repart il avait rien fait un peu
d'apaisement tout le monde d'ailleurs
était un peu surpris heureusement dès le
lendemain il se déplace sur lendemain et
il donne un peu de mépris à ceux qui
manifestent avec les casseroles bon
c'est pas très violent les casseroles
c'est pas très agréable mais c'est pas
très violent ce n'est pas bien quand on
veut apaiser quand on veut diagonologies
avec tous les Français on ne méprise
personne
les gens ont le droit de manifester ils
sont contre qu'ils continuent à être
contre la réforme des retraites il faut
pas mépriser quand on veut après
réinviter les syndicats à la table
finalement cela montre qu'Emmanuel
Macron va avoir du mal à tourner cette
page de la réforme des retraites la
mobilisation ne va pas s'éteindre
pendant 100 jours il n'arrivera pas à la
tourner il faut attendre la fin de l'été
et peut-être un changement de cap pour
vous voilà ça va prendre plusieurs mois
à tourner cette page de la réforme
retraite quel changement quel changement
de cap vous souhaitez bon alors le
changement de cap c'est il va falloir
pouvoir rassembler donc il faut faire
des
mesures qui rassemblent tant que des
mesures qui divisent je suis pas sûr que
la loi sur l'immigration quand bien même
il y a des besoins soit à même de
rassembler le pays je ne suis pas sûr
il faut peut-être la regarder avec un
peu plus le Parlement aujourd'hui je
sais qu'au Sénat ou le texte devait
arriver avant les vacances avant les
vacances parlementaires les vacances
dans un centre de départements de France
c'est pas les vacances à Paris mais
c'est les vacances ailleurs en France et
bien ce texte a été reporté sans inédier
et il est certain que ce texte doit être
retravaillé il ne passait pas
aujourd'hui la barre ni du Sénat ni de
l'Assemblée nationale donc on voit bien
que ce n'est pas prêt sauf à faire un
49-3 mais peut-être qu'ils sont
dorénavant vaccinés sur les 49-3 ça
serait quand même souhaitable donc ce
texte donnera semble pas le texte sur la
fin de vie je suis pas sûr qu'il
rassemble beaucoup non plus les Français
il y a plein de mesures à prendre vous
savez quand même sur la transition
écologique on n'a pas eu grand-chose on
a toujours pas la loi d'orientation par
exemple sur la transition écologique
alors qu'on fait des tailles sur le
nucléaire d'un côté sur l'éolien de
l'autre et on sait toujours pas quelle
est notre histoire on a plein de choses
que l'on pourrait faire pour notre pays
qui serait plus faire œuvre de
rassemblement et là on est il veut faire
oeuvre de division il dit non j'ai
raison et je continue à passer en force
et je n'écoute rien alors c'est ça ce
problème il écoute rien ni personne
alors en pleine crise de la réforme des
retraites et bien le patron de la CFDT
Laurent Berger a annoncé qu'il
quitterait ses fonctions au mois de juin
est-ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
Emmanuel Macron sans doute je crois que
la rupture était consommée c'est
peut-être un ami mais alors ça ressemble
à l'habit de 30 ans vous savez de
Edouard Balladur Jacques Chirac au 20e
siècle en 95 et si c'était présenté la
contre l'autre là c'était un peu la même
chose il n'y avait plus de dialogue
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour Alors c'est l'un
des grands chantiers d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a été annoncé lundi dans son
allocution impact pour la vie au travail
est-ce qu'on connaît déjà les grandes
lignes de ce texte alors c'est un vaste
projet qui devrait contenir plusieurs
textes d'après les différentes
interventions du chef de l'État
notamment dans les journaux du groupe
Ebra aujourd'hui on devrait voir arriver
très vite un projet de loi sur le plein
emploi avec notamment une réforme du RSA
et un travail sur le partage de la
valeur ajoutée portée par les syndicats
les mesures de la réforme des retraites
qui ont été retoquées par le Conseil
constitutionnel devrait aussi revenir
sur la table on pense par exemple à
l'index senior qui devrait être
retravaillé l'emploi des seniors la fin
de carrière devrait aussi être des
thèmes forts pour le reste Emmanuel
Macron ne veut aucun tabou parcours en
entreprise transition professionnelle
rémunération notamment pour les branches
en dessous du SMIC légal
usure professionnelle condition de
travail lutte contre le temps partiel
j'ai fait la liste vous voyez rien
exclus dans cet inventaire à la Prévert
alors Monsieur bachel le CDI senior qui
a été retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui était porté par les
républicains est-ce que vous voulez qui
reviennent dans un nouveau texte oui il
doit revenir dans un nouveau texte mais
ce qui ne va pas c'est que la réforme
des retraites devait être portée dans un
texte global et c'est bien ça que nous
avons aussi reproché au président de la
République lorsque nous avons écrit le
CDI senior en fait cette proposition au
Sénat et bien on avait bien conscience
qu'on était à la limite de la
constitutionnalité mais c'était aussi
pour pointer le fait que il manquait
beaucoup de choses dans ce texte pour
clariforme soit juste comprise c'est pas
le tout nous on a été pour la retraite à
64 ans mais il fallait pouvoir expliquer
comment on arrive à 64 ans
et aujourd'hui on ne le sait toujours
pas et donc ce texte est incomplet vous
parliez par exemple du RSA qui s'occupe
du RSA les départements de France ce
sont les départements j'ai écrit la loi
sur le RSA je peux vous le dire il se
trouve que j'étais en charge de ce sujet
lorsqu'il y a été créé et bien
ça c'est bien le département qui en a la
main mais est-ce que vous croyez que les
départements étaient associés à ce texte
n'a absolument pas absolument pas donc
une fois encore on veut s'occuper des
rémunérations où ce sont aux entreprises
aux branches de travailler et donc le
dialogue social n'a pas lieu pour
préparer cette loi je rappelle qu'il y a
eu un très bon ministre du Travail de
Jacques Chirac qui s'appelait Gérard
Larcher avec lequel il y a eu une loi
pour qu'il y ait six mois pour dialoguer
pour les partenaires sociaux
et bien quand on dit qu'on veut rouvrir
la porte à l'Elysée au partenaires
sociaux il faut laisser les six mois il
faut parler aussi au département je
viens de le dire il faut parler à tous
les acteurs quand on voit qu'on veut
aussi modifier les missions locales dans
France travail édition locale ce sont
encore les collectivités qui s'en
occupent et on passe au-dessus de tout
le monde il y en a assez ce président en
fait exactement le contraire de ce qu'il
dit deux jours avant c'est
d'insupportable donc une loi présentée
dans les 100 jours une loi sur le plein
emploi c'est impossible selon vous 100
jours avec 6 mois de dialogue social
vous voyez il y a un petit décalage non
vous savez c'est 100 jours je crains que
deux étapes il y aura une loi sur le
plein emploi pendant les 100 jours et
puis ce pacte sur la vie au travail qui
serait discuté jusqu'à la fin de l'année
le pacte c'est très bien on laisse les
partenaires sociaux faire leur travail
et à la fin c'est ce que prévoit la loi
s'il n'y a pas d'accord à ce moment-là
l'état reprend la main le Parlement
reprend la main mais là il faut pas
aussi trouver des majorités
alors vous l'avez un peu évoqué
Alexandre je vais revenir dans le détail
pour ce texte sur le plein emploi le
chef de l'État veut donc un projet dans
les fameux 100 jours mais c'est là que
ça se complique parce que les syndicats
ne sont toujours pas revenus à la table
des négociations mais mardi ils ont
boudé leur rencontre avec le président
et il ne devrait pas y avoir de contact
avant la grande manifestation du 1er mai
ou Laurent Berger a prévu de casser la
baraque en tout cas c'est ce dont il a
appelé de ses vœux mais même le patron
des patrons Geoffroy route Baisieux qui
était reçu par le Chef de l'État
avant-hier a prévenu il a tiré la
sonnette d'alarme et il a prévenu c'est
le calendrier est trop court aussi
d'après lui écouter
on prend c'est que Président le
gouvernement souhaite mieux associer les
partenaires sociaux dans les discussions
futures moi j'ai raffermé que 100 jours
c'était trop court pour arriver à des
conclusions et avoir le temps de la
négociation trop court pour le patron
des patrons la majorité a fait le
service après-vente hier le sénateur
Alain Richard était sur ce plateau il a
porté quelques précisions écoutez
vraisemblablement une partie de ces
travaux vont se prolonger je crois qu'il
l'intention est dans les trois mois qui
viennent beaucoup de choses seront mises
en route et en effet après il y a une
sujet disons d'attente de résultats et
il faut qu'il y a un rythme il faut que
les décisions qui sont prises porte
c'est faire relativement vite il parle
donc d'une mise en route l'exécutif
espère du moins fixé un solide
calendrier d'ici trois mois et puis
Emmanuel Macron a précisé aussi qu'il
souhaitait laisser du temps au
négociations alors bon c'est un peu
compliqué on laisse du temps mais on
veut aller vite qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez monsieur Bachar je crains que
c'est 100 jours se transforme à la fin
en Waterloo mais Waterloo c'est le 18
juin et là ça sera le 14 juillet où il
verra que tu n'auras pas avancé car il
n'a toujours pas la bonne méthode et on
a notre sujet sur les partenaires
sociaux Geoffre route des yeux arrête
son mandat aussi de patron du Medef
peut-être son numéro 2 c'est Martin qui
sera lui succédera donc il connaît bien
la négociation ce sera peut-être
d'autres candidats
la CFDT change de patron de patronne en
l'occurrence je crois c'est pas encore
fait mais c'est comme ça qui a annoncé
même Léon d'autre part la CGT vient de
changer de tête aussi il va falloir que
ces gens-là après à se connaître faut
voir sur quel mandat va être élu nouveau
patron du Medef donc il y a aussi des
échéances dans les dans les syndicats au
patronat et donc aussi important de
respecter cela ce n'est pas la date du
président de la République qui se veut
mettre des horloges toujours qui peut
faire que les choses avancent et je vous
le dis pendant une centaine de jours le
dialogue n'aura pas lieu parce qu'ils
vont continuer à être sur la réforme des
retraites jusqu'à temps qu'on ait c'est
à dire de nouvelles équipes qui pourront
passer un peu outre les engagements et
le combat qui a eu lieu sur les
retraites et en tout cas le président de
la République veut très vite mettre sur
la table la réforme du RSA et
conditionnée le versement du RSA et bien
à 15 à 20h d'activité ou de formation
pour les bénéficiaires de ce revenu de
solidarité active est-ce que cette
mesure ne peut pas finalement tendre
encore un petit peu plus le pays avec
certains qui disent que finalement on va
culpabiliser les plus précaires de notre
pays on sait pas de la culpabilisation
mais il y a deux choses je vois que le
Président de la République a une vision
très optimiste des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui au RSA
les côtoie pas donc il ne les connaît
pas vous avez une partie des personnes
qui sont au RSA dont l'employabilité
comme on dit voilà dans un terme affreux
est nul ils ont besoin du RSA et pour
vivre et leurs conditions personnelles
ne leur permettent pas physique mental
désocialisation est-elle que il y a à
côté
utopique aujourd'hui à dire que tous les
allocataires du RSA pourront faire ces
travaux certains le pour certains le
peuvent certains font du RSA et un peu
de travail au noir sans doute tout cela
est vrai mais aujourd'hui vous savez les
entreprises recherchent partout dans
tous les secteurs et du nom qualifié
mais il vous faut il faut vouloir aller
parfois travailler et les conditions
sont pas toujours simples et faciles
donc on va avoir un décalage qui va se
faire entre les diverses personnes qui
sont au RSA voilà la vérité le RSA c'est
pas un truc unique c'est pas une vision
où il y a que des tricheurs c'est pas
une vision où il y a que des gens qui ne
veulent pas travailler mais c'est aussi
une c'est soi-disant pour réinsérer mais
l'insertion elle est déjà faite par les
départements bien souvent vous savez
quand vous avez des chantiers insertion
on en a plein dans le département de
l'Oise avec Nadège Lefebvre et bien
oui alors j'aurais pas cibler les choses
mais on le sait tous qu'il y a beaucoup
plus de
d'allocataires
en théorie que qu'en pratique
en théorie on en voit des gens on sent
que 20 ans 130 ans 140 ans et tous leurs
allocations ça se saurait s'ils avaient
cet âge-là donc on a un problème de
vérification ça a été fait pour
notamment tout un tas de gens
effectivement qui ont cotisé en France
et qui sont repartis dans leur pays
quels qu'ils soient quel qu'il soit et
pas spécialement au Maghreb avec
certains qu'en France il y a eu d'abord
une immigration venant du Maghreb c'est
la première zone de d'origine des
migrations en France mais de là à
stigmatisé je n'aurais pas fait alors en
tout cas bon on va arrêter de de se
mentir on estime que cette fraude à
l'étranger c'est à peu près 200 millions
d'euros le compte n'y est pas si on veut
lutter contre la fraude fiscale et
sociale mais toutes les mesures sont
bonnes à prendre donc c'est pas le plus
important c'est de cette fraude sociale
qui évoque Bruno Le Maire par rapport
notamment une fraude fiscale qui
représente des dizaines de milliards
d'euros de pertes pour l'état non ce
n'est pas effectivement
là-dessus sur cette fraude particulière
il y a l'argent à prendre l'argent à
prendre il est sur la TVA et là sur la
TVA il y a quelque chose vraiment à
faire
et donc politiquement selon vous
pourquoi Bruno Le Maire appui sur cette
fraude sociale notamment en citant les
pays du Maghreb est-ce qu'il y a des
visées politiques
peut-être la télévision je ne suis pas
dans la tête de Bruno Le Maire ce que ce
dont je suis certain c'est que
effectivement ce sont plutôt là où il en
appelle les chibanis les cheveux blancs
en arabe et shibany qui eux pardon au
micro
repartent dans leur pays qui parfois
décède dans leur pays et la famille
continue à essayer de toucher les
allocations il y a plus d'allocataires
effectivement
au Maghreb peut-être qu'ailleurs mais
qui nous montrait chiffre machin on va
évoquer les questions politiques puisque
lundi dans son allocution Emmanuel
Macron a évoqué une réforme des
institutions pour résoudre la crise
démocratique et aujourd'hui dans une
interview donnée aux journaux de l'Est
de la France le président de la
République indique qu'il va utiliser le
référendum sur des sujets de son choix
est-ce que le référendum ça peut
relancer la vie démocratique de notre
pays
et pourquoi pas en faire un sur la
réforme des retraites
le problème du référendum c'est la
question simple et si la vision
simpliste alors je veux bien qu'on
traite tous les grands sujets par le
café du commerce je vous vois moi-même
le café tous les matins au café du
commerce dans ma bonne ville de Senlis
mais ce n'est pas là où on fait vraiment
la loi le détail ça c'est assez
compliqué et il dit sur les sujets de
mon choix je rappelle que il y a deux
formes de
référendum et on ne fait pas ce qu'on
veut comme il croit bon de le dire le
président de la République il y a un
moment il faut aussi que le Parlement
soit d'accord sur le texte qui va être
présenté et si le texte est présenté
c'est qu'il a été débattu il y a bien
quelque chose et bien une réforme au
fond qui a été préparée et pas
uniquement oui ou non sur la couleur du
drapeau français donc selon vous quelles
sont les bonnes mesures pour relancer
notre vie démocratique
mais il faut d'abord essayer de trouver
des majorités au Parlement et moi je
trouve que le Parlement aujourd'hui il
est surtout à l'Assemblée nationale il
est un peu dispersé il y a pas de
majorité donc il cherche des majorités
de projets il en a pas il en trouve pas
on l'a bien vu sur la réforme des
retraites je crois qu'il est aujourd'hui
dans une impasse je pense qu'il va
falloir retourner effectivement devant
les électeurs ah oui pour moi il
faudrait retourner devant les électeurs
donc vous plaidez pour une dissolution
de l'Assemblée nationale
démissionne et c'est une élection
présidentielle pour redonner un souffle
et puis après dissolution pour redonner
un parlement un nouveau ou une nouvelle
président de la République soit il sera
obligé de dissoudre à la fin de l'été je
pense devant l'échec des 100 jours donc
la démission d'Emmanuel Macron c'est une
option pour vous et vous savez si son
intérêt c'est celui du pays alors il ne
peut pas rester devant un blocage
démocratique tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
quatre ans de blocage c'est pas possible
ou alors il va faire de la réforme est
ou des choses très importantes moi je
l'appelle par exemple à faire à
travailler sur la simplification voilà
un truc qui énerve bien les Français on
pourrait simplifier dans tous les
domaines réformer vraiment son
administration plutôt que d'avoir des
ministres fantômes qui sont sous un
inconnus de planquer trois pas toujours
compétents alors il y a une autre option
c'est que les républicains prennent leur
responsabilité et forment une coalition
de gouvernement avec la majorité
présidentielle vous le souhaitez une
coalition ça se fait soit une coalition
électorale avant les élections soit
juste après pour en tirer les
conclusions aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
rien de possible c'est impossible
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus possible car
les moissons
et si le peuple on a décidé fraîchement
comme cela alors on peut dire c'est ce
que le peuple a proposé en ayant une
nouvelle Chambre des députés en disant
un nouveau président de la République
et donc un moment en responsabilité on
peut se soumettre quand même à la
volonté du peuple et là il y a trop de
décalage entre la volonté personnelle et
Emmanuel Macron et de ce qui a été la
volonté du peuple de moi après il a
oublié de faire campagne un souvenez
vous il a pas fait de campagne
présidentielle il n'a pas soutenu
Elisabeth borne et son gouvernement lors
de les élections législatives et bien il
a aujourd'hui la majorité de ce de son
fait donc il doit en tirer lui toutes
les conclusions il étire toujours pas on
continue à parler de politique Jérôme
bachel on va faire un tour dans votre
département de l'Oise on va retrouver
nos partenaires du journal Le Courrier
Picard avec Jean-Marc chevaucher
rédacteur en chef adjoint au Courrier
Picard bonjour Jean-Marc
bonjour on va évoquer avec vous l'enjeu
des élections à sénatoriales dans l'Oise
ce sera en septembre prochain ces
élections sénatoriales
oui et ben comment on fait monsieur
Bacher déjà on est sûr qu'il y aura plus
de femmes à droite puisque tout le monde
veut faire sa liste monsieur Courtial
vous et
Olivier Pacaud sans doute qui avait créé
en 2017 alors je sais pas s'il va la
créer un nouveau cette fois-ci ça me
paraît un peu plus difficile mais en
vous allez me répondre si on vote pour
si les élus votent pour Jérôme Bachir
ils seront sûr d'avoir une femme
puisqu'il vous en aurez une en deuxième
position mais plus sérieusement pourquoi
avoir fait trois listes et pourquoi
avoir
adhéré vous vous comme comme Édouard
d'ailleurs qu'on doit courciel son micro
parti l'oiseau cœur et puis vous vous
êtes rapprochés de Monsieur Lisnard
vous n'êtes plus républicain si alors
attendez on va repréciser le contexte
les règles des élections sanitaires
c'est d'avoir des listes de candidats
paritaires c'est-à-dire une femme un
homme une femme un homme ou alors un
homme une femme et
ensuite et actuellement dans l'Oise il y
a trois sénateurs de droite et ces trois
sénateurs dont vous faites partie du
handback Cher pourrait présenter trois
listes différentes justement pour
contourner ces règles de parité c'est
l'objectif non ça ne compte l'objectif
n'est pas de contourner les règles de
parité la fois dernière j'étais sur la
liste des parcoursial nous sommes
arrivés largement en tête nous avons
placé que deux sénateurs et vaccourcir
la abandonné son le département parce
que interdiction du cumul de mandat
Nadège Lefevre qui était numéro 2 a
choisi de prendre le département et je
suis devenu sénateur par la suite je
crois que nous trois nous sommes trois
sénateurs qui faisons le métier de
manière différente avec des options
parfois un peu différentes sur
différents sujets sur
notre proximité avec le président de la
République sur nos étiquettes moi je
suis les républicains je et j'essaye que
tout le monde se rassemble plutôt que
chacun soit dans sa propre chapelle donc
j'aime beaucoup vous aviez Bertrand tout
le monde le sait et donc j'essaie que
nous France produisent des idées il y a
eu l'énergie de David Disney qui s'est
lancé dans l'Oise je suis voir et avec
Nadège Lefebvre nous sommes dans
l'animation du département au niveau LR
histoire que tout ça montre bien qu'il y
a sa fourmi d'idée que chacun a le droit
de réfléchir mais qu'à un moment il faut
se rassembler et moi je serai candidat
pour une liste de rassemblement donc
voilà non clairement il y aura trois
listes de droites hommes a priori mais
c'est à gauche qui était qui avait une
sénatrice monsieur chevauché madame
rossignols
et c'est un de ces combats remarquable
connus et reconnu elle arrête au profit
a priori d'Alexandre wizi qui est un
jeune élu socialiste voilà donc c'est il
y avait une sénatrice et alors non ce
qui est assez embêtant vous avez raison
quand même c'est que admettons que les
résultats soient à peu près identiques
aujourd'hui je pensais que vous
conserverez vos trois postes de la la
majorité sénatoriale je suis assez sûr
j'en ai pris d'engagement de gérarchie
les trois les trois places de majorité
sénatoriale resteront
merci beaucoup Jean-Marc chevaucher pour
votre intervention sur les élections
sénatoriales dans l'Oise on va regarder
la une du Courrier Picard aujourd'hui
qui est consacré au service national
universel merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
cette interview Jérôme bachaire
j'appelle vous êtes aussi inter les
républicains de l'Oise merci d'avoir été
notre sénateur du jour merci